You might remember from the second unit that we can draw a matrix like this.
Where here in the columns we have what a deterministic RAM can do,
and here we have what a non-deterministic RAM can do.
In the rows we have polynomial time and exponential time.
You already know 2 complexity classes that go into here.
One is P, and the other one is NP.
There is actually also names for these classes up here.
This one is commonly referred to as EXP or exptime.
You can guess what that stands for.
This one over here, guess what, is called nexptime.
Since we are this far in the unit, here is a little challenging quiz for you.
Because you can actually arrange all of these complexity classes here
in a sort of hierarchy.
Meaning that, for example, all problems that fall into this complexity class here
automatically also fall into this complexity class here and this complexity class here.
It's basically a hierarchy or containment of the complexity classes.
I am going to give all of the complexity classes over here a number. 1, 2, 3, and 4.
What I would like you to do is to enter the number of the respective complexity class
so that you have built this hierarchy over here.